hello everyone welcome back to roller
coaster Guthrie and today I'm going to
work on this building right here which
doesn't exist yet but it will in the
near future and you may notice while
watching this episode that some things
have changed in the let's play pike and
I'm going to confess I have actually
worked in this Pike without actually
recording it I said that I would record
everything for my let's play but that
just didn't happen for a number of
reasons first of all there is the fact
that my computer was loaded with files
and I didn't really have space anymore
to record more and I also didn't want to
wait to commentate over that and render
it so I could remove it and make space
so I was just like Yolo we're just going
to do this without recording and then
there was the fact that it was just kind
of that type of work in the game which I
don't think is really fit for timelapses
I mean the main reason that I'm doing
these timelapses is of course that well
it's much faster otherwise the gameplay
in what Costa can three with me even
more boring and that would be great but
it also means that you know it's cool to
see their progress on buildings and
things like that but the issue with that
is sometimes you build things that
aren't really cool to see progress or it
takes a very long time to see the
progress like recoloring things or
experimenting with certain sets things
like that is definitely something I
would at least try to not time lapse and
what I did is mainly something that I've
been planning to do in this park for
quite a while but only now got to
because you know I'm entering the stage
of the park where I'm trying to finish
everything and that is just go to places
all over the park look for things that I
think are unfinished or then I can oh
that i think i can add something to in
the meantime since I've got new sets and
new knowledge and yeah things like that
so what I did for example was I went to
the castles near the entrance and added
some small details to that especially on
the towers like those golden balls and
sexy things because you know it's a
fantasy card so after I can just go
overboard with that but I'm still not
too sure if in the future I'm going to
feature this in time lapses which I
probably won't do or if I'm going to do
something with it that i'm just going to
completely skip it and only do it in my
livestreams because i work
on this Pike mostly in my livestreams
and the last option which is something
that I'm probably going to do is to have
some real life episodes I mean a real
time episode every time I say real life
and now that may seem a bit weird
because I it's not really the entire
idea of this series but then again it's
something that I've done with the
layouts of my roller coasters and for
some reason those real time episodes are
the episodes that most people watch at
least have the highest amount of viewers
and I figured you know what I haven't
really done too much real time video
stuff in Monaco second three so it might
also be cool to just hear my thoughts as
I built things because it is definitely
a lot different to commentate over
something after you've done it all so
it's kind of easier for me it is
definitely easier i'ma say to just
commentate over things that you're doing
at the moment while you're doing it
because at that point you know you get
all those thoughts about it and you can
just throw out your thoughts when if
you're commentating over pre recorded
footage you definitely you know need to
keep thinking about things to say and
what is actually relevant in the case of
the video that you're watching and in
this case that would be this small
building over here which is kind of like
a mirror image of the building on the
other side of the facade of the what do
you even call that thing that pirate
ship that also rotates it's for children
in any way but I like those things and
it has the same kind of style with those
pillars and everything but as you can
see definitely using other SATs although
there is something about Ralphie's
pillows and that small I don't even know
what it is kind of thing from boy blue
set because you have those pillows from
Ralphie and you can just add the boy
blue kind of brown thing to it which
almost makes it seem like a fancier
pillow but in reality it is not even a
pillow but these pillars are shy guys
Main Street pillars just because they
you know that different I'm trying to
feel like there was at least some kind
of difference between architecture even
if it looks kind of the same in shape
and size I I do want to have some
variation in it and also there is the
bank then more and more I'm starting to
feel like Ralphie's antique world is
starting to get over
used because seriously my now is
building Verona Valley rarely anyone was
using it and if people were using it
they were often using it wrong including
me because no I have the gymnasium in
Dutch in Dutch land which has like which
comes with the study of classical
architecture at which point I realized
that everyone's idea at least my idea
and people i knows ideas were actually
wrong about classical architecture
because there's a very strict hierarchy
and rules that you have to abide to when
it comes to building those buildings
which is possible within Ralphie's
antique world but rarely anyone really
does it even the preview screens of
Ralphie's Andy antic well don't strictly
follow the rules of classical
architecture and that's something you
don't necessarily need to do but head to
something line I noticed and now that
Ralphie SAT is getting used people are
at least using it in the right way I
guess but you know it's still something
I I don't hate it because it's overused
that would be a very hipster ish
approach not that anything is wrong with
that per se I guess it's just a natural
thing to do but and that's not the main
reason its many about the fact that if
people overuse something in veliko
second three you're gonna notice it much
more it's going to be almost immersion
breaking which you can have immersion in
roller coaster get three you can truly
be well inspired is not the right word
but truly feel like you're in a park or
wish to be there or truly feel
overwhelmed by put somebody's built but
it really works better if you don't
really recognize the SATs and if
somebody uses the same set over and over
again that so many people are also using
which is Ralphie's antique world at some
point and you know you can you just
recognize the pieces you just recognize
the things that they've done and to me
that is almost ruining the experience I
mean if somebody builds a beautiful
building using the set I can still
recognize that but those are something
immersion breaking about the fact that
you recognize the pieces and recognize
the fact that everybody's using those
pieces at the moment so that is also why
sometimes i like to resort to
underground sets that vary but really
anyone users that aren't that great
as opposed to using great sets that
everyone uses because you know something
just seems to be wrong sometimes about
using sets that are just so common that
you recognize them instantly and
recognize the fact that they are so
commonly used now this building over
here is made up of not really too
overused sets but then again they're
pretty common seriously but and I didn't
like the mixture of sets in that
particular building it has the pillows
from Main Street sent as I said and it
uses then I still don't even know what
it's called but that triangular kind of
dirt patch thing I didn't even know what
it's supposed to be used for from boy
blue and then there are some random
things from the western set as well and
i must say that station Jim's western
sets I think I don't really know the
exact name but not just might be the
name at least it's a good enough
description I guess they really have
some awesome pieces that go so well
together with the Alpine sets even the
walls because they have that same kind
of stucco texture that actually does fit
with the Alpine sets and of course
that's the bell tower which is pretty
damn sexy but the cornices are also
something that you can't miss about that
set it's really amazing and it can be
used with so many more things than just
western sets than just western scenery I
mean and this belt oh it's really just a
simple bell towers and these buildings
on the side I'm gonna be honest these
buildings in the side over here just for
sods to kind of fill up this area even
more because I was trying to get that
kind of city idea so I wanted to at
least surround this square by buildings
all around but if you're surrounding a
square with buildings what you often
have in real life you'll have most of
the buildings or filler buildings and
then you'll have some buildings that
really stand out and that just gain your
attention but you would want to have
some kind of filler buildings around
that which is kind of what's happening
over here the carousel building is
obviously the most detailed and most
classically Theme Building over here and
definitely the center of attention of
this square but you know you do want to
have some of those Alpine buildings on
the sides so
it's not completely empty you don't want
to really have a square like this in a
middle of a forest that wouldn't make
too much sense at least not in this
context so yeah honestly these buildings
are just kind of filler trying to make
them look as good as I can with the
least effort well that's not really the
word you know you won't yeah I guess I
could actually say like that to be
honest sometimes I'm late are you okay
yeah I did want to go for the least
effort in this case but I also didn't
want to make it look to you know
standard so using loads of pieces from
different sets the arches over at the
bottom are from my alpine set thing I
don't even know what my own set is
called and the arches on top of that are
from Ralphie's and then there's coconut
is out arches so in the arches alone
there's a lot of variation in this
building but it's definitely something
that I've done before because all of the
sets used in this building have been
used throughout the park this is
honestly just a kind of feel of building
it's nothing too special and the bell
tower is simply there because you know
every every town needs a kind of bell /
church tower and you know this building
serves that function i guess and pretty
well i still want to look at those
flowers because there might be an
overload of flowers over there and
they're not really the most creative
flowers it's really just the flowers
that's that everybody uses in a random
order which I know that say to good idea
I kind of want to get into that entire
thing or flower arranging and I know
this sounds incredibly stupid and like
I'm 70 year old and but I you know it's
something that really appeals to me for
some reason it's something I've never
tried and you can actually create really
awesome figures with flowers so on to
give that a try but anyway that's it for
this episode in the next episode I am
probably going to do that real time
episode in which I'm just going to run
over the park look at details and
probably say a lot of things about the
park and you know just kind of review it
before we actually get to finish it add
some details to it and then record a
video which going to happen at a much
later stage because there is so much to
be done still so I'll see you then